my name is Elsie George I'm an author
and a filmmaker I'm from Brooklyn New
York from the area's number of their
neighborhoods Crown Heights is where my
family started my mother and father live
there when they moved here from Virginia
in the 50s then we moved to era called
Brownsville which is with notorious
for years and years as the home of
murder incorporated that's where the
real tough Jews come from the a lot of
the biggest Jewish gangsters of the 30s
and 40s into the 50s live there and we
were part of the wave of black and
Latino sort of immigrants from the south
and from Puerto Rico who moved there and
so I grew up in this area that which was
the has echoes of Jew of Jewish and
there's temples and their streets and
there's institutions that go back to the
30s tenement buildings
Alfred kaizen wrote a book called Walker
in the city which is actually about
Brownsville and it's kind of about
Brownsville as it was becoming it was a
Jewish ghetto then it became a black and
Hispanic ghetto and we lived in some
great society housing projects that were
built during the 60s under Kennedy and
Johnson and we lived there more or less
into the 70s they were moved into era
called East New York which is farther
out toward Jamaica Bay and we kind of
were part of a group of folks who uh I
always said we chased the white folks
out of out of Brooklyn because we were
every neighborhood we lived in one
basically had been either a Jewish or
Italian neighborhood pretty much and by
the time I you know I've been here three
years they'd all basically left or going
to the Long Island or Florida or
wherever people went back then so that's
my background I'm a very much a Brooklyn
guy I live now I've lived in Fort Greene
Brooklyn for over most of my adult life
now I would say I moved there in 84
maybe late 84 85 so I've lived in Fort
Greene when that was kind of a dodgy
area and then it became kind of a Black
Arts
area where Spike lived on the corner
from me Spike Lee tons of musicians from
the from Lester Bowie and the world
saxophone quartet guys to Vernon Reid to
just tons of artists and painters and
designers and that's sort of in my area
since the now it's become incredibly
gentrified area and in fact for me has
probably changed more I believe since 84
let's say so it probably changed more in
the last three to four years than it had
in previous 20 so all those things shake
me yeah it's something you have to have
very mixed feelings about it one thing I
liked about Fort Greene was that it was
predominantly a black neighborhood that
had white people in it so it wasn't like
living where I grew up in the project so
it was basically just working-class to
poor folks it had a really nice mix of
working-class people from the projects
black homeowners white homeowners had
Bam's in that neighborhood has been
there forever so you had arts
institutions there and area always had a
very artsy vibe I mean they were the
first time I saw Erykah Badu and mos def
was it a poetry spot on Fulton Street so
it would had that kind of at least I
witness at least two to three
generations of black artists who lived
there and now that they all spoke savvy
they made a ton of money and moved out
or I have been replaced by younger black
black artists but now you have a white
presence like we used to have sort of
older homeowners who live the
neighborhood now we have it's a you know
all the people who couldn't who got
chased out of Chelsea and chased out of
Lower East Side and chased out of
Manhattan are there because you can live
in Fort Greene and have access to the
city I'm most depending on a subway
three subway stops from lower Manhattan
uh you have a great Park and you have
BAM and you have a number of great
cultural institutions so I am I I like
the fact that gentrification has brought
in more restaurants I mean we always
used to say it was only like three
places to really eat in a neighborhood
now we have about five French bistro
and Mexican and you name it we have you
know you can actually spend your entire
weekend in for greens the for green area
and go to movies go to plays go to jazz
get a club have great food go shopping
but definitely has been the cost the
neighborhood is is beginning to resemble
aesthetically more the not even the
village would like the Upper West Side
we're having an incredible expansion of
skyscrapers into a brownstone
neighborhood there's like out of my
bedroom I can see two being built and
there's a lot lot more coming so I think
that the neighborhood that I loved is
being changed by gentrification
profoundly just as the city is and the
bottom line is it Giuliani sort of made
the city safer along with Bratton and
that whole strategy Bloomberg has made a
city safe for real estate developers and
so places like Fort Greene even places
in South Bronx you go all over the city
there's probably more big buildings
being built in Manhattan and in Bronx
and Brooklyn Queens and it's been again
in my lifetime just so much development
which is driving out not just you know
middle and lower-income people but also
driving out the businesses that support
them so I don't know where someone on
the west side gets to their shoe shined
or you know the laundry or the you know
watchmaker there's all those little
craft shops that did dot at the city
little businesses that supported
residential neighborhoods and now you
have these skyscrapers these but these
little building you know get your keys
made on what you get your keys made you
know there's things like that there are
very simple parts of life but find when
you don't have that usually realize how
essential the key-maker is and the
Schumaker is or the shoe fixer is more
importantly and and those things are
being pushed out of city and so we have
this really weird we have people with
lots and lots of money and lots and lots
of skyscrapers and not actually and a
lot sorts of restaurants but every other
kind of service to to it's important to
living a good life it's kind of being
chased out of town by real estate
you